when I realized what was going on with
mass surveillance and in my own
experience tried to bring it forward I
encountered a very very different world
from always thought was in training
everybody in my supervisory chain
everybody in the leadership who saw
these things that wow that is a problem
that doesn't seem right there seems like
we've sort of gone too far here and then
immediately follow up with but look you
really don't want to get involved in
this you know that's not your job let
this be somebody else's problem if you
put your name on this picture to destroy
you
it's fair to say that if there hadn't
been a Thomas Drake there could have
been an Edward Snowden
there was critical actual intelligence
than si had about Al Qaeda and
associated movements I discovered to my
horror both pre and post 9-11
intelligence that they had kept from
others and intelligence they didn't even
know they had